I was convinced that light doesn't
actually slow down in water and I
thought I'd mathematically proved it too
but then I did the experiment and
reality decided to completely contradict
me so I really am roll since then I've
spent a lot of time trying to figure out
why light acly slows down in water and
the thing is it's complicated and I
still don't know but I feel like this is
something I've heard about like
progressively over the last year at
various different phases of like now
it's makes complete sense down to like
oh wait if this was true then does that
mean that you're perfectly cancelling
out what the wave would have been in
this like strange packet that do seem to
make sense like there's these waves
hopefully at this point you've seen
Grant's beautiful explanation of why
light should in fact slow down in water
now that argument is based on chapter 31
of the Fineman lectures and the thing is
is I'd actually read that chapter before
I did the experiment and I'd completely
believed it as well and yet I was still
convinced that light wouldn't actually
slow down in that experiment the reason
is that Fan's argument shows that the
phase velocity of light decreases when
it goes into water but phase velocity is
not what most of us mean when we talk
about the speed of light imagine that
Alice and Bob want to send a message to
each other and they've decided that the
best way to do that is by sending some
light between each other for example
Alice might send a pulse of light to Bob
that has some pre-arranged meaning when
we talk about the speed of light in the
setup what we clearly mean is the
distance divided by the time that it
took light to get from one end to the
other we'll call this the information
speed because it's how quickly a message
could get from Alice to Bob and I think
that it pretty much intuitively captures
what we mean by the speed of light the
experiment that I did with the lighter
on my phone was very similar and setup
to this my phone emitted a pul of
light and we measured how fast that took
to travel through the water the result
of that experiment was that the
information speed slows down
significantly so this is the thing that
we need to explain but in vman's book he
considers a completely different
scenario instead of sending a short
pulse of light Alice sends a plane wave
which is a wave like this the thing with
plane waves is they're not real they
extend infinitely in both directions and
are the same for all time they just keep
moving along like this which means that
this wave has been here forever before
Alice and Bob even existed people often
say that a plane wave is like a Pure
Color of light like a laser but actually
these aren't light lasers at all because
lasers have to be turned on at a certain
point of time and then they turn off at
a certain point of time whereas this is
like you had a laser that's always been
on since the start of the universe
that's what makes them actually
completely useless to Alice and Bob for
for sending messages when Bob sees this
light he's not going to think this is a
message from Alice he's just going to
think oh well it's the same as it always
is that's why it's not possible to talk
about the usual speed of light or the
information speed of light for a plane
wave because there's no time difference
between when the light was at Alice and
when it was at Bob it's always been
there but for this type of wave there is
another way to define the speed look at
one of the Peaks and then look at how
fast that Peak moves
along this this is what we call the
phase velocity in physics we really like
to talk about the phase velocity not
because it's real or a good measure of
velocity but just because it's easy to
measure so for example in Quantum
Computing we often we're talking about
like phase differences um because it's
really easy to figure out if a wave has
been shifted like this because you can
compare it to a wave that wasn't shifted
and then you can do this like
constructive and destructive
interference stuff to figure out how
much of a shift it was the other reason
that physicists love to talk talk about
phase velocity is because it's far
easier to prove things about plane waves
and phase velocity than it is to talk
about more realistic light Fan's proof
is about plane waves and it proves that
the phase velocity decreases but usually
proofs about plane waves generalize to
regular pulses of flight pretty well by
using something called the fua transform
so the fua transform in this case claims
that any pulse of light can be made up
of a lot of different plane waves added
together here I'm going to add a few
plane waves together and look how
quickly they basically become a pulse so
here's one 2 3 four and five plane waves
basically already your pulse
mathematically that is true but from a
physics perspective I hate it I mean
you're saying that this little pulse of
light that I just happened to turn on
and turn off is actually made out of
basically an infinite number of plane
waves that stretch out into Infinity in
both directions and have been on since
the start of the universe and will
continue forever like that just that's
just not true is it let's go over the
main idea of Fan's proof and I'll
explain why it's enough to show that the
phase velocity does go down but I'll
also explain why I thought that that
proof showed that the information speed
stays the same so here's the setup of
that proof let's say I have this
container full of water and I have this
massive light here that's Shining Light
into the Container if we just look at
the electrons in the First Slice of this
water we'll see that each of them is
getting hit by light we're assuming the
light is coherent which means that all
of this is the same kind of light you
can see that first there's a peak here
then there's a trough Etc now imagine
that we want to figure out what happens
to an electron that's further down in
the water somewhere if the other
electrons weren't in the way then it
would only get hit by the Light that's
directly in front of it but it's these
other electrons being here that make
makes all the difference and that's
because each one of them is going to
emit their own light in response to the
light that's hitting them remember that
happens because when electrons get hit
by light they oscillate and when a
charge particle oscillates it emits its
own light which is in the opposite
direction of the light that hit it so
you can see this electron light is in
the opposite direction of the original
light that hit it um Grant pointed out
that that actually isn't quite right
because the electrons actually OS the
total force that they experience and in
this case there's actually two forces
they experience so they experience the
force from the light but they also
experience force from the atoms pulling
them back to where they originally were
and so depending on which of those two
forces is stronger the direction of the
electron's light may be in the same
direction as the other light or it might
be in the opposite it doesn't really
matter for the rest of the analysis but
I thought that was interesting so wanted
to point it out so the light that hits
this electron further down the line is
going to be a combination of these two
bits of light crucially the light coming
from these electrons isn't just going in
the forward Direction the way that this
light from the lamp is that's because
when the electrons oscillate like this
they emit light in all directions
although most strongly in the forward
Direction They also do emit some light
that's for example pointing this way and
going to hit our electron if we just
look at two of those pieces of light
you'll see why this is such a big deal
initially these two bits of light are in
sync with each other even though they're
still in sync here it's a very different
story when they get to here the reason
that matters so much is that you can
imagine all of these electrons sending
out messages but because all of the
messages are being sent at the speed of
light that means that some messages are
going to look like they're lagging
behind if they're coming from further
away it's the same effect as when we
look into the night sky and the further
away an object is the more it looks like
it's in the past in the same way some of
these electrons are going to look like
they're really lagging behind we can see
that when the Light reaches this
electron here this light is at a peak
while this one is at a trough and so
they actually kind of cancel each other
out at this point from the perspective
of this electron this light is lagging
behind this electron is seeing that
light as it was in the past so even
though in reality all these electrons
are bouncing in unison from the
perspective of this electron it's going
to look like actually they're not in
unison and the further away electrons
are further back in time the overall
effect is that the light is a little bit
shifted backwards from where it should
be because some of the light from the
electrons is old light that is just now
reaching the next layer it makes sense
that if a plane wave gets shifted back a
little bit every time it goes through a
layer of electrons that overall the
phase velocity would decrease but what
about the actual speed of light does
that decrease according to this argument
well I didn't think so because remember
firstly that all of these waves are
infinite so we can't even talk about
when they get to the next electron
because they've kind of always been
there so first let's just cut these
waves short which means that they're
only approximations to plane waves now
we can talk about how long it takes for
them to arrive at the next electron but
this like coming from further away
doesn't arrive as quickly as the more
direct one and so it will look like it's
going slower than the speed of light and
that's just because it went on a less
direct route and it takes longer for the
light to travel that longer path however
the strongest bit of the light which is
the original light plus the light from
the electron in front does go on the
most direct path and so it will look
like it's traveling at the speed C and
so if this electron was measuring the
speed of light by counting how long it
takes until it gets hit by light it
would say that the speed of light is
still C yes it will experience other
light coming in later but for the speed
measurement all that matters is the
speed of the front of the light because
at that point it can confirm that it
received a message from the previous
layer here's another maybe simpler way
to see the same argument I'm going to
deal with just really simple light like
this it's like I turn this lamp on and
off very quickly I found it so confusing
to the point of not believing it that
light like this could really slow down
in water and that's because of this
really simple argument I had which you
might remember from last time so here's
how it went when this light hits these
electrons the electrons hit back with
their own light when you sum all of that
up you're going to get something it's
going to be complicated so let's not
worry exactly what it looks like but
it's going to be some light there and
this is going to happen for every layer
so whenever the original Light reaches a
new layer it's going to jiggle all of
those electrons and they're going to
immediately respond by producing some
complicated function of light another
way to think of it is that whenever this
original light moves into a layer it
immediately produces some light from the
electrons so we know the original light
is traveling through the water unimpeded
going at the speed C and we know that
it's producing this electron light as it
goes but when we're talking about the
speed of light in water what we care
about is not the original light or even
the electron light but the sum of them
together as soon as this light gets to a
particular layer it will produce some
electron light in that layer and that
will add to some resulting light and so
there will be some resulting light
that's in this layer so the resulting
light is traveling just as fast as the
original light did because they keep in
time with each other think about it from
the perspective of someone who is timing
how long it takes for some light that
was shown on one side of this container
to get to the other
side they stopped timing as soon as they
detect some light and because that light
was just keeping in time with the
original light the amount of time it
took for that new light to get across
the water is exactly the same as if
there was no water there at all this
argument seems watertight but it's not
it's actually wrong and we know that
because the experiment showed that light
really does slow down in
water morning so I spent a lot of time
last night thinking about um where I
should go from here but the thing is
that as a theoretical physicist I've
hardly ever done anything besides you
know relying on just pen and paper and
Mathematics um I mean I hardly did any
experiments in my under grad I would
always just try my very best to get out
of labs and so I kind of like you know
didn't have that in my um tool belt and
that's what this series is about I I
wanted to like learn how to do
experiments but uh now that I've done
this experiment I don't know how to
interpret it except through my usual
methods and that didn't work um so I'm a
little lost so where to go to
next I think what I'm going to do is I'm
going to try and
um do some computer simulations of the
stuff that I'd been calculating I I had
intended to try that anyway um but I
thought it would just be a way to like
confirm the things that I already knew
but now that I must have some sort of
mistake in my um mathematics it would be
good to try and use the computer to like
actually explore what's going on um but
the thing
is uh I don't know how it occurred
that's right it's time for a learning to
code Montage I wish that this was as
easy as this video makes it look but it
was really not but eventually I did get
this working what I did was I simulated
Fan's whole argument with all of these
slices of electrons and I managed to
show that plain waves really do slow
down in water which was so exciting so
the next important thing I needed to do
was show that pulses of light do slow
down in my simulation now I was pretty
sure that this was going to happen
because this simulation was just based
on two things Fan's original analysis of
plane waves which only basically assumed
some stuff about electromagnetism so
that seemed Rock Solid and then to
upgrade that analysis from plane waves
to pulses I used the Foria transform to
write the pulse as a sum of a bunch of
plane waves and then I did the analysis
for each of those plane waves and then
added them back up the F transform is a
mathematical fact and so stuff based on
that is basically guaranteed to work I
know I went on and on about how it's
cheating to use the fio transform before
but I think in this case it was and it
wasn't like I don't think it was
cheating because I just wanted to use it
to confirm at least mathematically that
this model would show that light slows
down in water like even pulses of light
would slow down but then after I'd got
that confirmation I'd figure out why
that happens without using the F
transform
at least that was the plan except my
simulation just wouldn't
work this was supposed to be the
straightforward part if this wasn't
working then it means that there's
something very wrong with Fan's analysis
but I had nowhere else to turn like I'd
read all these other textbooks and Fan's
derivation was the only one that made
any sense at all I mean I've gotten so
desperate that I asked all of my physics
friends and I even started like cold
emailing a bunch of fonics professors
yeah nothing worked and I had no way to
fix my explanation and even though I'd
spent months and months on it at this
point um I started feeling so sick to my
stomach every time I thought about it
that I decided I just needed to give up
on this
project some months after I'd given up
Grant convinced me that I should just
make a video about this project even if
it didn't work out and so I Revisited my
old code and it was terrible like I know
I was a beginner but man that code was
so bad to read in fact it was so bad
that I just decided to scrap the whole
thing and rewrite it in a few
days it's like
midnight and I'm coding look at
this those waves travel pretty fast till
they get into here and then they just
sort
of well they're all over the place but
okay let me show you the simulation
that's slightly more convincing than
what you just saw okay this red light
gets Shawn into some water and what
happens is it continues going at the
speed c um but this purple light is the
new light that is resulting from the
original light plus the electrons light
and you can see that that is going a lot
slower and you can tell because um see
this dot here the red one is something
going at the speed C whereas these ones
are reduced ones the blue dot actually
represents the phase velocity of the
main frequency in this light but the
Green Dot represents the actual
information speed of light and they're a
little bit different because there's a
difference between basically the group
velocity and the phase velocity it's a
little bit technical but it's actually
kind of cool that um I can show you this
I've just changed the parameters a bit
so the refractive index is less than one
and it actually is possible for the
refractive index to be less than one in
real situations um but you might have
thought well that must mean that the
speed of light is suddenly greater than
C in those mediums but that's not true
the phase velocity is greater than C but
the information speed or like the group
velocity is less than C all right so you
can see the original light coming in and
it's still going faster than this
resultant light but here's something
interesting see the blue dot is going
faster than all three of them if you
follow one of the peaks of the purple
light then you'll see that it's
traveling at this phase velocity whereas
the overall shape of this light is
traveling at the group velocity or the
information speed of light here you can
see this a little bit more clearly the
blue dot is going to keep in time with
that first Peak but the Green Dot keeps
in time with the actual light and what
this shows is that even if the ref
ractive index is greater than one the
information speed of light is always
less than C in a medium I guess there
were just some bugs in my code because
now it was working and the simulation
showed that b analysis does lead to the
conclusion that the information speed of
light slows down which is great until I
remembered that I could of already knew
that the information speed slows down
right like from the experiment what I
wanted to get from the simulation was
hopefully some insight into why and this
simulation based on the fio transform
was giving me none of that for example
it correctly showed that if you have a
pulse of light going through water
eventually the new pulse of light will
lag so much behind the original light
that's traveling at Sea that the two
will become disjoint the only way that
this could happen is if the electron
light exactly conspires to add up like
this so like the electrons have to make
this crazy two peak distribution where
the first Peak is traveling at the speed
C but somehow the second Peak is
traveling at the Speed 3 over4 basically
some of the electron's light has to
travel fast enough to cancel out the
original light entirely and then some of
the electron light has to be traveling
at a slower speed this is the only way
to get around the argument that I made
earlier because basically I was assuming
that you would never have this situation
where the electron light cancels out the
original light exactly honestly that
felt impossible it felt like way too
much of a grand conspiracy on the part
of these electrons and so I just didn't
believe that that could be possible the
simulation based on Fan's argument tells
us that this must be what happens but it
gives very little insight into why
because it doesn't really let you
directly see what all the electrons are
doing so I really wanted to understand
this exact situation not the one with
plain waves but with these real pulses
of light but the thing is this
calculation was just way too difficult
because you have to imagine the effect
of every electron on every other
electron and this all simplified down
really nicely when you're working with
plane waves but it doesn't simplify
nicely at all when you're working with
actual light and so that's where I got
stuck what I needed to do was write a
simulation that directly models pulses
of light like this rather than using
plane waves in the background the
problem was that that simulation would
be a lot harder to
write all right I figured out how to
make my simulation stop blowing up which
is very exciting so let me show it to
you one thing to note about the
simulation is how painfully slow it is I
tried to vectorize everything but uh I
couldn't get it to work and so in the
end everything is just a full
loop What's Happening Here is this red
thing is the light that's entering a
medium so the medium is represented by
these electrons there's actually 175 of
them in this simulation I haven't drawn
them all because it gets kind of crazy
in fact it's kind of crazy with them
here right now but I'll take them out
for the rest of them anyway what's
happening is that you can see that the
light oscillates these electrons and
they jiggle about and hopefully
eventually they settle back down but who
knows anyway the more important thing is
the purple line so the purple line is
the total light um so it's the sum of
the red light which is the original plus
the blue light which is what's coming
from the
electrons we need that purple resulting
light to be going slower than the red
original light but let's see if that
pans
out first let's look at the simpler case
or at least what should be the simpler
case so here we have the red light being
a plane wave and what we expect to see
is that the purple resulting light
should be um like a smaller wavelength
and also should be going slower right
now the electrons are acting completely
crazy like their light is all over the
place but that actually kind of makes
sense because in um Fan's thing he
assumes that the electrons are in a
steady state but actually it takes a
little while for the electrons to settle
down so let's give this a second and now
we can kind of see the behavior that
we're expecting you see how the um
purple light now looks like it's kind of
lagging behind the red light and the Gap
kind of grows it sort of does look like
the light is slowing down which is
pretty
surprising I'll show that to you again
so you can see whether you agree with
that and I'll take out the blue light
because I think it's a little bit
confusing and I'm going to speed it up a
bunch
so for the plane waves this just about
works at first the behavior is a little
bit crazy but then it does settle down
and kind of gives you what you expect
which is that the new light seems to be
traveling a bit slower it's a little
hard to tell but it it looks like it
probably is and it seems to have a
smaller wavelength but for the pulse of
light I couldn't even get it to actually
slow down and I don't know why exactly
that is it might be because I just need
to have more electrons in the simulation
and um more time elapsed but like this
simulation is very very computationally
expensive and I haven't been able to run
it with like much higher parameters than
this so maybe that's it or maybe there's
something more fundamentally wrong um so
it's kind of hard for me to draw
conclusions from this simulation at all
like it kind of looks like the front of
the um original light is getting worn
down by the electrons as they go through
which is what I suspected must be the
answer that like as the light travels
through the water at every layer the
electrons just shave a little bit off
the front more and more until eventually
that original pulse just basically gets
cancelled I think that must be what
happens and the simulation kind of kind
of suggests that but it's really not
enough to draw a solid conclusion about
there's still so many bits that I don't
understand and it's very frustrating cuz
I thought that if I wrote this
simulation there has taken so much work
that it would just give me all of the
answers um instead I just have this
thing that like frustratingly half works
and I I I don't know what to think this
whole thing started around Christmas of
2022 for me and it's almost Christmas
again and honestly I think it's time
that I admit that I don't know why
lights slows is down in water I feel
awful having to admit that on a video
but I guess I'd feel even worse if I
made a video where I pretend I know the
answer and it sounds right but I'm kind
of hopeful that maybe by telling you why
this question is complicated and
interesting some of you might want to
take it up and if you do and you make
some progress then I would really love
to hear about it so yeah let me know in
the
comments